today we're talking about new world's
giant march update and how fortnite
looks to be bringing back lightsabers
the latest update for amazon's mmorpg
new world will arrive tomorrow march
29th and it looks to be the biggest
update to the game since launch both in
terms of new content and the huge range
of quality of life changes at the
forefront of the update is the
conclusion of the game's current main
story with a new quest that will lead
players to the new tempest heart
expedition to confront isabella tempest
heart won't be easy however with amazon
recommending players be level 60 and
have a gear score between 550 and 570 in
order to succeed the other star of the
update is the new blunderbuss weapon the
first weapon in the game to scale with
strength and intelligence a close-range
powerhouse the blunderbuss has two
distinct skill trees to choose from with
one more focused on aoe damage and crowd
control abilities while the other is
about dishing out damage at extremely
close ranges while the new expedition
and weapon are definitely highlights
there are a huge number of other changes
that should go a long way towards making
new world a more enjoyable experience
those changes range from removal of
costs associated with moving items in
storage between towns the ability to
check your inventory while moving and
the addition of infinite low tier ammo
for ranged weapons just to name a few
for knight in star wars crossover events
are nothing new and it looks like this
partnership is set to continue by
bringing back the franchise's iconic
melee weapon a leak has revealed that
lightsabers might be coming back to
fortnite in a future update a fortnite
data miner has apparently discovered
that chapter 3 season 2 will add four
different lightsabers including kylo
ren's cross guard luke's green
lightsaber rey's blue energy sword and
mace windu's purple blade players will
apparently be able to strike and block
with the lightsabers just like they
could when these four lightsabers came
to fortnight before lightsabers were
initially added to fortnite in 2019 and
came back in may of 2020 to celebrate
star wars day with star wars day 2022
coming up on may 4th 2022 it seems
likely that lightsabers could return to
fortnite around then and speaking of
things coming back to fortnite how do
you feel about the no build mode and do
you want building to come back because i
finally tried the new update over the
weekend and i don't want it to come back
i'm good with it staying just like this
forever let me know in the comments
though
sonic the hedgehog and friends will soon
be indulging their sweet tooth when they
appear in candy crush saga in
celebration of sonic 2's theatrical
release sonic and tails will join the
match 3 puzzle game march 31st to april
4th however only those who have reached
level 25 will be able to participate in
this special event players will gain
energy by breaking a special sonic spin
dash candy inserted into puzzles and
that energy can be used for completing
tasks in a puzzle treasure hunt quest
the event will also feature sonic
inspired music and sound effects created
by candy crush developer king
specifically for this event
but okay word on the street is that
playstation is going to be revealing
their service that competes with xbox
game pass this week so keep your eyes
open and your ears open do not sleep
just sit there and refresh our youtube
channel so when it gets announced
and we make a news update
you know about it